Of that but thank you the
one that says push. Good
evening everyone let me begin
by- thanking god father John of
the resurrection church for
making this facility available.
You are here to participate and
what we call- lovingly in
Sacramento budget subcommittee
number three- but that's
subcommittee as part of our
important budget process. We
oversee not just natural
resources issues including the
department of toxic substance
can troll who you will be
hearing from later- but also-
oversee transportation agencies
and- transportation issues who
have a very broad jurisdiction
in the subcommittee but- up.
Today as so we were two years
ago when we were here
resurrection church we her to
provide oversight regarding the
exite clean up and as- chair of
the subcommittee I want you to
know that I have followed and
worked on this issue for
several years now- for those of
you who are here for the second
hearing I think you know that
we've been- closely following.
The clean up to make sure the
proper oversight occurs. And to
after several years the sub
committee- has taken a number
of actions to approve funding
to clean up the contamination
caused by excited there's been
a total to this day of two
hundred and fifty seven. Point
six million dollars in general
fund money that's been
committed to the effort. The
purpose of the hearing today is
to get an update from the
department to- on the status of
the clean up. To ask how much
of the allocated funds have
been encumbered liquidated and
finally to hear about the
coordination- that is occurring
between the department and the
Los Angeles county office of
public health. Before I offer
my colleagues the opportunity
to say a few words I want to
take care of for a couple of
housekeeping items- of everyone
who is here who would like to-
address us in at- public
comment. Will have an
opportunity to do so before we
close out the hearing. Of we
are going to circulate comment
cards which are over to my
left- and- if you're interested
in making a public comment we
ask that you write your name
down those cars will be brought
to me and I will call them.
Probably in groups of three so
that you can come forward and-
know when you're speaking time
will begin. There's also of
physical copies of the agenda
that- available and I think
those are also over to my left-
but today you can find the
agenda online as well if you
want to see it online. There is
a- website to attach to the
budget subcommittee and Susan I
don't remember what the
addresses for the budget
subcommittee so. Okay anybody
needs it ceases. So without for
further do I want to pass-
whether have to pass the
microphone I will- I ask my
colleagues would like to add
some comments and welcome them
at the same time so welcome to
assembly member Cristina Garcia
and- Miguel Santiago anything
different over who's going to
go first your available. Thank
you I know it's Friday and adds
the in the fight it in the long
weeks I want to thank all the
community members and folks who
are here tonight and I've been
here for many years working on
this I also want to thank the
chair of but is that the for
being a good partner in this
and staying on top of the work
continues its being that in and
the staff with the committee as
well I think it's commendable-
that our colleague has been
committed to this issue. Of
whether it's in this district
or not it's in the state and so
I do appreciate that continue
to. Support I'm gonna I'm gonna
be. Really short there are
certain this here for you to
get tested I hope you take
advantage of the maybe have an
already we know- that the
process and then perfect and so
just think you do the community
who continue to advocate to
help us learn to do a better
and so I. Look forward to
getting the update with you-
and getting direction. As you
continue to work. I do hope
that we- are I do believe that.
We've been learning and it's
not perfect that and so I
understand the frustration and
the work that's ahead and so I
don't want to minimize that.
But I have seen some progress
out there. And I am committed
to continue to work with the
residents in the activists and
continue to take advice along
the way. On and then to thank
you to our supervisor for
always being. A such a great
partner and in the separate to
making sure that it's not just
a state but the county and
other regional. Agencies are
with us and so with that it's
Friday homeless get on. Thank
you. Thank you ms Garcia.
Mister Santiago. Yeah thank you
don't go the many thanks to-
all our colleagues here here
miss Garcia- Mister bloom and
certainly our our very own. I'm
supervisors to lease- and one
thing the community really for
and all the commuter
organizations and all the
different books Y. C. out their
father Moreira. The
resurrection community and- I
started list and I'm we'd we'd
be here for awhile because-
this is been a long challenge
and if you are is aggravated
and upset. And is frustrated at
not getting done quickly and
fast. Believe me it's the same
feeling people have here. And
part of this part of this.
Coming here tonight. Is to add
the pressure to get this done
quicker now we have a real
unique opportunity it in the
sense that were still dog on
getting this thing done. I am
getting it done in the
quickest- most rapid way
possible. I know we also have a
new in from director over the
TSC. So there's a real
opportunity- for embracing a
new approach to this in asking
the real tough questions at
this point in time right. Why
is it costing so long why why
is it taking so long- where
their answers that suffice we
accept them with those answers
that don't suffice- we don't
accept them when we challenge
those things. On it and our
colleagues here. I believe the
been support of our recent
efforts certainly. I know as as
our community members
organizations- and supervise
least audit- do TST. As it
relates to. Only introduced-
the letter. And will continue
to make sure to try to advocate
that the- that the state
legislature. Voted up so that
the- stick- honor can actually
do it's working on it. And it
will be able to come back with
best practices. And what really
did happen and what's going on
so when I can. Thank you one
more time for continued-
advocacy. I can't say enough
that I live in the same
neighborhood. And granted my
kids have not. Been alive as
long as some of you have been.
Fighting with this good fight
but the impacts are real. I'm
not within the one point seven
miles- the but I would agree
that you. That that they still
have an impact. Or land like to
along some of the- toughest.
Neighborhoods is released the
pollution. Without rail road-
rail rail line's we've had.
Heavy diesel to drives around
heavy industry not too far away
from here with fifty five
thousand cars driving in our
land locked around freeways. I
mean you know you you you live
here too. And like you will are
my kids also suffer I got with
has my- severe asthma. So
believe me that this fight is
just as personal- for me as it
is for you. And this is part of
the X. as a getting this done
in one of think. Again all our
colleagues and supervisors
lease for being here and really
challenging the status quo so
that we get this done. In the
quickest and highest quality
way. First thing we ever said
we got when we got started on
this so thank you. Think of
symbol. You're welcome and
thank you again- both of you
for being here we are
expecting. Of one more
committee member to arrive
shortly- but I do want to take
a moment to welcome supervisor
Hilda Phillies who were going
to be hearing from on- the
second. Panel social have an
opportunity. To address your
concerns at that time but- I
want to thank. Supervisors
police for being here
participating in this event and
also the county for helping to
organize the event. So our
first panel I will. Now and I'd
like to welcome our speakers
for that panel. Meredith
Williams who is the- very new
director of the department of
toxic and substances control. I
think- a director- Williams has
been on the job for about six
weeks now- but you'll correct
me if I'm wrong by a couple
weeks on. On that. I and we
also have grant cope with the
deputy director for site
mitigation. They'll be
providing us with an update on
residential clean up at. And ms
Williams you- I'm sure I have
seen the questions- that are-
in the agenda and if you could
work your- comments if you
could work into your comments
responses. To those questions
would appreciate it. Welcome to
both of you. Thank you very
much thank you chair bloom. And
thank you to the other assembly
members who joined us here
today. My name is Meredith
Williams and I am the director
for the department of toxic
substances control and with me
today is grant cope our deputy
director for site mitigation
and remediation program. There
are many other staff here with
us as well as- it is of county
PA. And hopefully that will
help us answer any questions
that may come up we do believe
that the presentation the
materials will be responsive to
the questions of the committee.
Thank you for hosting this
meeting in the community- we
always welcome the chance to
provide. Up to date information
and to. Keep people abreast of
our work overseeing the cleanup
of both the facility and the
residences impacted by the
contamination from excited. I
know you're eager to your to
hear directly from the
community and we actually have
found that the more directly we
can hear from the community the
better off we are in terms of
how we do our work. So we
appreciate another chance to
hear feedback directly on their
variances and their concerns
and yes their frustrations. A
few weeks ago I had a chance to
come down and visit some area
residents and also to meet with
some members of the work crews
who had gone through the
workforce development program.
Part way through the day
Andreas Andres Martinez who in
his or somewhere- who leads are
workforce development team
program team- commented about
the number of stories that have
come out in the course of doing
this clean up work. And I'm
sure you more than I have heard
stories of loss and of illness
and of the told contamination
takes. On the people who live
in the scan these communities.
Throughout the day I did hear
other stories. I got to see the
closeness that is develops
sometimes between a resident
and the staff member buys them
shoot through the clean up
process. I heard families talk
about going to great lengths.
To take care of their pets
during the clean up. One
resident told me she can now
host family gatherings in our
backyard without fear of.
Letting poisoning for her
family and another resident
another- couple talked about
how they now have divided their
responsibilities for
maintaining their their yard-
an integrated into their daily
routine. I also heard from
three brothers who found the
that work on the clean up
through the work program and
talk they talked about what
have what happened steady
employment has meant to them.
And it was really quite.
Affecting and I think all of
these stories really represent
how internet the work we're
doing is. We're entering
people's homes were helping
them relocate pets were talking
to them about why it's so
important to me ups done.
People are placing a lot of
trust in us. And we take that
responsibility very very
seriously. And we can only do
this work if we maintain some
deep level of engagement with
the community so we're
constantly striving to
strengthen that can our
communication. And to do better.
The residential clean up is
progressing settling we're now
able to clean up about a
hundred properties along. We
don't have any we haven't
encountered many so significant
technical issues with the red
presidential clean up recently.
Our priority is to clean up as
many homes as possible and to
that end we streamlined a
number of our- some aspects of
the process and- simplified
some things and we also think
that will help drive down the
cost because as we said. The
priority is to clean up as many
homes as possible and so we're
being. Increasingly aggressive
about containing costs. We're
doing our best manage the
budget but we are facing some
high contractor costs and
project cost increases. This
evening in addition to talking
about the facility in the
residential clean up and will
provide- will to this evening
will also provide information
about how the facility closures
going an update you on that so
there is a lot to discuss. And
before I get to that just one
more story which is that toward
the end of the visit when I was
out- visiting various
properties a group of young
school girls walked by in their
school uniforms on their way
home from school. And I
actually started wondering what
their stories were. On whether
their homes in been remediated.
Was it okay for them to play in
their backyards. What what is
the lead done an impacted how
it impacted them. Gave me
pause- we understand the
importance of this work. And
it's has to be done
collectively has to be done in
a ship with everyone who's here
this evening. And this is
another opportunity to really
strengthen the that partnership
and- continue to work so with
that I'll turn to the
presentation. So today will go
over the rest of. So the boss
about back hello. What is
required to do under. On talk
about the boat park is clean up
and the retention. Talk about
what we doing in terms public
age meant around that. Will on
the force. At which point out
that over the grant and health
about budget contracts. Sec as
a reminder what the bloody.
Like if you go yeah this this
is what. Before we begin the
clean process. And is there the
three segments were there and
this is a picture that was in
in October- and as you the
segment one long hair. And
focused on segment one segment
yeah I do- some of the crop
attention to say to into the
coverage the sweets maybe
artist but there is covering-
of the pull up structure there
and up isn't yours in that. In
that include. That of it. The
approach for the demolition and
clean up the first the to do
that we can phases the for
phases to address all of. Route
structures and the deep
structure in the D. emanation.
And we're- moving. And bring
that back to be we take great
pains to make sure that the
work. Done so please and this
work X. is risk some of and
it's higher labor. The cost and-
state funded being for that for
this work. Dahle about ground
structures will merge into the
low and. Can and do an
assessment autumn report clean
and that as after we that there
may be a phase three is needed.
So with respect to phase one.
And that that stays is more
than percent complete. At this
point on. We can one since
twenty six. And but we are
significantly behind regional
time estimate schedule or how
long it would to do work. Fact
team months and the of the low
the- amount on it will be. This
one moment cation will be were
bring exile do. Us one permit
modification on a scale change.
As we got. In the one tale up
review of this proposed
schedule change in the in and
public comment period so- look
for that and would be happy to
report on on that as as it goes
forward. So and then I didn't
want me to. In order and then I
want to- talk a bit about the
facility in closure as I
mentioned- and as the slide
illustrates there have been. In
they've been great cost. In the
unit yeah- they are a polity
when happens is an air quality.
Violation and it's all so- over
the procedures that putting
putting the for free and fair
and then a second bridge. The
end of your- and- after the
first pre. Coast it is a
violation and we be December.
The second bridge are you in
January should. More than a
statement late we actually have
recall them back look at this.
For your- the- issue is so that
the would tell us where is
being added I'm and skin and
then all of. But certain things
are really forced to be those
bono. Is a- to be thank fact
have drinks at work actually
complete leave me. So keep an
eye on. And closure and make
sure. To stand. On you know the
is get back to a drop this is.
To be invest mission D. R. X.
is responsible for doctor
thorough testing hello
contamination old enough. And
they needed an of what we Rick
refusal investing to us deemed
it it in at. And as a result we
reject that were and have take
taken steps to take to make
sure that a proper
investigation gets done and
also what we call a corrective
measures study- however excite
is disputing our determination
that that- that that. Are a
five- report that report is
insufficient and were in
dispute resolution resolution
process nevertheless were
working to make sure that that.
The things are in place of that
that investigation can be
completed properly. That's
where we are with the facility.
And move on to the park ways
and the residential areas. And
it's been about the ways should
spend is but where are of and
that getting Burke wasted
levels of can nation taking act
if completed the same. Of ways
and- we also issue next year.
So for our because men and it
actually up in for. The good
stand how. Breaks loose news.
Part is important to the right
so done that we talked asking
to help is the ways. Buses
address in Europe all got of.
We expect out of those
documents available by summer a
and a public com. Into the
clean out based for the rest.
The residents clean up yeah I
think it when he as well
miglior with with the- one
seven preliminary invest. There
are if we take a number there
are more than a thousand
missiles within them one point
seven mile radius with a simple
for the five hundred of the
house. And as of this week the
teen hundred X. the properties.
There are six hundred thirty
still. There we have not. Where
we have not been going back to
sample board to do clean. Right
now we have three three. Is an
old and says that's been done
to contractors allows us to get
a hundred. I want to talk a
little bit about what process
look like. And what steps we go
through when we clean up. First
is the and permission to sample
and- up and door property Asian
special school board and
convert shins folks in the
process what. It moved. He for
instance after in the process
of the to be okay and I don't
buy into choices for what for
they want in proper and work
out all the D. and the
scheduling details and once
that's all done Reese schedule
the clean up again working very
closely with the resident
making sure that- they can
manage the logistics and
whatever else it's just
obviously very destructive to-
day to day lives and so we've
taken a great deal care with
the scheduling. And then.
Eventually of course the clean
up clean up crews go into the
field and do the work the
excavation and the remediation
and- after that's done we do.
Sit down with the resident
confirm that the clean up
workers comp the we have
quality check lists- and we
make sure that. Everything's in
order. So you can see there are
a lot of touch points
throughout this process so it's
really not possible to get this
work done for not in good
communication with the
community. And I want to talk
about. It more- there's just.
The site it is to our- water
order do. Or not and where to
get thanks you. Understood the
problem the- we have a local
person com. House be more
simple. Do a number mail I do
are. The yeah website eight
here ace the start also in two.
To make sure that we get the
word out about. Activities the
area meetings at Centro we only
to we not only can mean but we
a we have into as my other on.
Meeting in areas possible and
we have our- thirty eight
member excite technical
advisory group. And so- Bob.
Keep talking come back to that
in a minute- so when you add
that all up and look at for
instance what does that
engagement mean. Is it for
instance in the nineteen.
Fifteen minutes the prince
communities and up we have
dedicated line hammer. We
encouraging people to call us
and tell us when you're of
problems right away three one.
We fielded fifteen hundred call
a hot last year. We do.
Educated with participation
daft age men name their- better
than committed. And when you
added a it's just a lot of.
I've been around. There's we
hope our a meetings your and
three can. And meeting of con
tap. And we do. The space
language interpretation is.
This we publish the age may
count or twenty not. Three
meeting and- someone. Just can
to provide our for to learn
about what's going on so.
Continue that engagement and
then of course folks we want to
make sure that when folks go
online they find the
information you're looking for.
Only a lot of progress and
information sign. One of the
questions asked. To speak was
corporation with also- were.
Others agency there are call
for the record and it. Mention
to some basic yeah this call so.
We are- we're needing with the
low jurisdiction. We help local
we have a monthly coordination
home with account. We have. Who
sharing information with the
lead abatement program it's a
very active. So I want to
switch gears a bit and talk a
little bit on a workforce
development program the
workforce for environmental
restoration and communities
this is a program that spent.
The rest of us. Anyway is a-
and have have Gen. Make sure
the community itself Bennett
that's begin. The clean up and
so of course look for. It is
through for Gramm leach. Either
with. Investigation finds quite
a number of a that we set our
local one. Get perfect in terms
of getting in program again.
Being an- the room at the end
this point on a team going up
well I have a chance to with a
number of. Who had through
program and are. Seventy one
graduate. We've gone through
six words different folks-
since. More clean up right now
there. One work is done the
proper. At the project uber
manly people are getting up we
and- and that get the community
Russell are benefiting from the
this opportunity as our hope is
that of course in the long run
backed- this will lead to other.
Opportunities other employment
opportunities perhaps through
the union there are many other
avenues of folks continue to do
this kind workers and tell
there were three. Once have
experience. So that's where we
are with the residential and
the- in the park with clean up
and at this point grant will
talk to you about the dollars
and cents. I'll be talking
about the budget the contracts
for the residential clean up
right now we start with about
one million dollars with
expanded about a hundred fifty
seven million dollars that
essentially these but ninety
four million dollars for the
remainder of the clean up.
About 81% money expand that's
far has been for the clean up
of Ste well. The person has
been for ample for and of the
money that we spend. Ridley to
clean up our act please. One or
clean up. Prop. The cops are-
for but at this. Thank you the
drop for. Contract we go in to
on the contrary we- both in
contract manage social help.
Okay the country of. As well
the way we- that's costs were
most. And to drop. What is the
time of con is. Time there if
you were was not workers will.
Office the next it. The does
tend of I track only in a
really. Cost is in a. Isn't it
over to. Cost play cost
materials have priest so.
Project it is center very long
black. Even if the price this
is the is it normal to cost per.
If you find term time material.
In context of the work you're
doing and what a as opposed to
it different of concept. Yes in
a time of contract you'll to go
out for the day and do a
property let's say takes them
ten hours to do the work and
they move- fifty cubic yards
off the site. They will charge
you for the full ten hours. And
they'll charge you to Holloway
those fifty cubic yards of
material. I won said another
site it takes them twelve
hours. To declare the property
and- the Holloway eighty cubic
yards of material. So they're
gonna charge you increased
amounts of money because around
the field longer in the movie
more material. That contrast
rather sharply with- type of-
contractor we're trying to move
into which is called the unit
price contract. That's where
all of the costs for certain
activities are spelled out in
the contract itself. To going
in and sampling. That's it
that's a set price. Moving
certain amount as well that's a
set price it just provides more
certainty for the state. For
the amount of work that they
can pay. For any particular
clean up. So I can see where-
there may be cost savings in
the second kind of contract but.
The time and materials contract
would seem to incentivize the
possibility of spending more
time the necessary on a job
site- but on the flip side. The
other contract. Could influence
in the opposite direction wise
one preferable over the other
night soon there's oversight
that's provided on uncle there
is a credit card. That you
you're absolutely right
troubling we have people out in
the overseeing the work done by
contractors- we- not not only
had have what we call- we've
got engineers you know other
individuals who will go and-
look at the quality of work
that they've done. Make certain
that they're doing it according
to the clean a plan that we
produced for this for this
project we also have other
quality controls which I can go
into a little bit. Where we
have when you say we are
talking about DTS city crier
department clear. Independent
of the contractor overseeing
that work that's right. That's
right. We also this is
important when a when a project
is done we'll go back and walk
through the property with the-
individual who lives there. To
make certain that the project
itself- got a list it's called
a punch last will go down it
just took off or something is
not- up to par for that
individual. And then will work
to try and correct that-
whatever that problem is. Thank.
Questions to- arctic now. The
it's just a curiosity right
because I would. I'd I I'd ask
you know why do we think about
the most efficient ways of
doing it from the very
beginning instead of looking at
the most efficient ways later.
I'm not I'm not that technical
expert on contracts right and
I'm not. That you won I did
speak with my previous
experience service community
college for dealing with
project managers told me that
there's a number of different
contracts that can be set up in
the onset right- you have open
book which will be laid out in
you determine the profit based
on open books and the different
names for them but they all get
the same thing- person-
percentage of profit. That
everybody agrees on Ansett
price- there is a there's-
would you say- there's a set up
amount and then it just depends
on how fission- program
managers are the maximize their
space in order to get the
largest amount of a profit
possible- and then there's a
set- well there's a number of
other will try but- the one
that at least efficient always
is the one that charges. Yeah
because the way it in in
oftentimes it's the highest
burn ratio on the program
manager side in. Ali a maybe
you are directly involved in
that but if I can understand
that I'm wondering how do you
TNC could not understand that
from the very beginning could
we struggled all the same
things we came on and- we-
completely reformed. S. and it
is difficult for me to
understand how how these things
could have been caught. Day one
in knowing the most efficient
ways to actually do a contract.
Yeah I know some remember- so
you're absolutely right my
understanding is the department
did try to go through a number
of different. More set price
contract structures here's the
problem this is one of the
largest most complex clean ups
if not the largest most complex
clean up that details he is
done and they clean up hundreds
and hundreds of sites all
across the state. When you're
trying to construct a contract.
For that type of- very
logistically complex and by
that I mean. Each one of these
parcels that is being cleaned
up is different. And so when
you're trying to construct that
without. Information that
people can use to gauge how
much money a particular parcel
will cost. It's tremendously
difficult to get a contractor
to actually sign the contract
because for them. The potential
exposures huge if they agree to
clean up say five on a
properties. And they come up
with an estimate on a per
parcel basis that turned out to
be wrong even on the margins a
couple hundred dollars five
hundred dollars thousand
dollars suddenly their
exposures far beyond what their
risk model would otherwise
except to what what did he is
he did was they tried to come
up with that you know price
contract at first. But they
just didn't have enough
information because they hadn't
cleaned up. You know five five
hundred eight hundred
properties so what they did in
particular I'd of the
tremendous amount of pressure
on the department actually
deliver the cleanups. Because
up until that time they've gone
through the E. I. R. process.
Which which is great comply
with state law. Back to a time.
Then they were in a position of
trying to develop a com the-
contract one of the largest
cleanups ever undertaken in the
state and people wanted to see
shot on the ground and so they
made a decision that would
enter into a time materials
contract. And also bring on
contract consultants to help
them both trying constrictors
costs but also over time once
they knew more about that the
kind of the risks inherent in
cleaning up properties that
they were trying to do a better
contract contact structure. Is
that the- answer. To going to
the next slide. There's some
additional activities of lead
to increased- clean up costs
that are just. Kind of inherent
within the- Daschle project
itself. In the case can you to.
Mobilizing remote eyes again
and then and that time. Sample
there is in the house dollars
are there are. Spent on being
their allies honest cleaning up
so some of to be expected. We
up. Guards we can we want to
and I'm- the time and force
duration this is their home so
we necessarily have to be
flexible scheduling but when we
do that there's an inherent
costs and that's just part of.
Working in an urban environment
where you're actually digging
up people's yards there's
change there's changes have
been made and landscaping
materials. That has a cat
coming. Because if you you plan
for a certain amount of clean
ups over a week. And if people
modify their request for say
them out of sight in the yard
or they wanna go from side to
rocks. You'll you'll have to
purchase that potentially on
the spot or you'll have to make
certain that you have that
moment. Actually cover those
properties if you don't then
you go out and buy it so all of
that also increases costs
there's- normal interact
interruptions for work such as
rain delays etcetera. So
recognizing this week we've
taken steps. Already to reduce
costs and burn in the midst of
the kind of final negotiation
period with some one of the
contractors to transition from
a time in which- contract to
unifies contract. That's really
the biggest cost driver right
now we've taken other steps to
reduce costs but just in terms
of overall impact. That's
really where we have our I sat.
And then park was funding-
legislature six point five
million. Dollars to do both as
well clean up. We can as- your
outlines state we clip pleaded
the leads twenty four the
number is. Expect about were we
needed which would we gonna
spend one point two million the
next. The next big step
process. On a contractor to
actually for parks. That's
that's what we're here for you
today and we're happy to answer
any additional questions
clarify things. Yes a he said
that you were working on a
contract change it's one of the
two contractors appealing which
contractors that. It's Parsons.
Okay can. I had the pleasure of
attending year community
hearing in the city about only
to see some of year passes
between the two contractors in
person being much more
expensive- all along the way
and concerns about even who
with the contract the- people
there to oversee that contract
and so forth where there was
some sort of. Indirect and
direct take to Parsons- along
the way and they spend. A lot
of concerns about the Parsons
contract in particular so in
addition to make in the type of
contract. A putting other safe
crisis there to address some of
the community concerns. So by
some of the other can you
concerns- one of the things
that we've heard is when
something is damaged on the
property they want to make
certain. It's actually fixed.
And so we do a process whereby
we work with the people who
live on the site. And if
something is damaged. We've got
that punch list that we go
through we noted. And then we
work with the contractors. To
make whatever middle steps we
can to address that that
problem another can I just ask
a clarifying question are you
are you are you hearing
concerns about oversight of
persons that's the so that's
part of your question is yeah
not just with the cost of the
actual oversight of the work
you're doing it right being
safe if- and so there's been.
Different such as average
that'll have one or the other
and what we care the most
concerned about the work that's
actually being done has been
tied to presence I do want to
speak to the safety issue
because this does come up and I
know there is a bit of. Fusion
because- folks look around at
the properties as a getting
cleaned up and they may see
people wearing different types
of safety protect in a
protective equipment. And it's
confusing to folks- because
depending on what stage the at
what stage the cleanup is. This
is the step the workers may be
wearing booties they may be
wearing other protective
equipment or if there's they're
handling the clean filtered
they may have less protection
and it's be it can be very
confusing and so we've what
we've done is we've- we just
ask people to call the hotline
if they have a concern but we
know that's one concerns.
That's out there- and I don't
know if you want to speak to
any of the other oversight
concerned about how we- how we
just not modern the contractors
in the field just on a day to
day basis. Yeah in terms of
addressing- safety issues on
the site the- there's a
requirements in these are all
spelled out in the clean up
plan where if- wind kicks up
above a certain- number of
miles per hour. We just check
the operation down we make
certain the swells covered-
during excavation activities
during dignitaries- we make
certain that the soil is kept
moist wet so doesn't blow up-
eight and to be able so they
can inhale it- there are
monitors set those up when and
down wind to ensure. That you
know we know how fast the wind
is going- and also were
monitoring to see if any of
that wind tech sector- within
the area. The those are some of
the kind of issues at least
that I've heard that a
percolated up- have you been
have you heard of anything in
particular that we haven't
mentioned. We could speak to.
I'm I think it's in a moderate
there's definitely are people
in the proper gear employees-
save. Are we making sure that
the third isn't playing around.
It's also the question of
whether and whether or not
there's full disclosure when
there might be a section where
they can't fully clean up the
soil and why is that. On and
then the finding out later so
it's there's a lot of here
behind what's the purpose of
all this clean up and- when
residents are being alerted to.
To these pockets that might
could be impossible to get to
what that means. The hearing
about that at the end and so.
Those are also concerns for
community members tied to the
par since work in particular.
Yes for both Parsons as as any
see. And this is because it's a
requirement across the entire
project. There's a map. That
is- basically created for each
particular a parcel. And they
will mark. Where there is oil
that is to say higher than
eighteen inches below. Ground
service. And they will know.
The depth to which excavation
occurred. So the- and that is
you know that is provided to
the residents of that if they
if they want to know exactly
where- excavation occurred did
not occur they have that as a-
as a- written document. But but
when I hear you're asking is I
that is that being communicated
in real time as the clean curry
so we'll look at that I
honestly don't know the
feedback loop on that and I
think that's something that we
should. Expect a thirty two.
Not just to finish off on that
spot. It's been felt by
community members that they're
finding out. At the end when
they're being told to sign up
the final thing off. And so
then they feel like well what
else he hiding from me or you
know and so. There might be a
logical explanation but in real
time it's not happening into
there's a lot of anxiety about
the work but after has. I know
it's been left behind that's
very helpful to hear thank you.
For this is that I have to many
questions again Mister chair
you can tell me if the second
was appropriate after the first
of. Soap my first question is
so if we had committed to the
to our neighborhoods and our
residents. A some percentage
cleaning up we've it costs a
little bit more the beginning
that means it subsequently less
homes to be cleaned up and now
we're going to scale up. Or
speed is a word used. In more
efficient in the next phase.
Where does that leave us in
terms of percentage of work
that was actually committed as
a been some analysis as if we
were still I know it's not a
hundred let's say if it was a
hundred is I guess eighty five
I mean what what's the
percentage. We have some idea
or can we get to the that full
commitment. So it's pretty
clean up a sixteen under
properties at sixteen hundred
and six properties. And we've
got- roughly ninety four
million dollars- to clean up
the remaining properties. We
know that that is not going to
get us to the full thirty two
hundred that we wanted to clean
up to. The question now for us
at least is going forward for
under a better. Unit price
contract structure with Parsons.
How how much will that drive
down the price and we don't
have a good handle on that
because we're not yet under
contract we think it's going to
substantially- with Parsons
could substantially drive down
the price so for example on
average persons around eighty
three thousand dollars per
parcel. We would like to get a
you know price contract. That
drops that down closer to
around 700-007-1000 somewhere
around there- were not yet.
Nobody has signed on the dotted
line so we don't know that
that's going to be possible
that would be a pretty dramatic.
Reduction in the cost per
parcel that they clean up. And
then each part of the clean up
in those reductions are
realized. More properties can
be cleaned up under that
contract that would have
otherwise been. Back in at this
point timer we fully scaled up
to expectations so the- so it
ebbs and flows across the year
because we're coming out of
both winner as well as
holidays- this is traditionally
the slowest time. For being
able to ramp up but we're going
into the spring. And so this is
the point at which we do want
to see people beginning to
about. Their operations. We're
currently- at thirty three
crews- but both- NEC is most
Parsons want to ramp up to more
than that. The sugar. In order
for a- this will as you might
talk about the non persecution-
agreement and what I mean so
people understand what that
means in. One what aye
remembers member the deep DTS.
US attorney's office had deemed
that. Excited would avoid
criminal prosecution if they
did certain things- part of
that with this plan and now the
date. Of DTS he's rejected the
plan that excite means what
that really actually means so
we have a grasp on it I think
you put your finger on it again
home. Director cope can speak
to this more in more detail
but- they signed up an
agreement in the settlement to
do certain things and that
included a thorough
investigation and- corrective
measures studies they haven't
done those things and so we
have asked the department of
justice to wave than on
prosecution. And to the chair
and what does that really mean
if they continued could they
win a case could they lose the
case what happens. Could date
when the case or lose a case.
If the you attorney gonna grow
are to remove to remove that
agreement. Yes they if they
withdraw the non prosecution
agreement basically non
prosecution agreement was built
on top of DTS these orders it
says comply with the tias he's
orders. After doing just said.
I tried is clearly failed to do
that we told them they have
failed to do that we have also
asked- the department justice
to withdraw the non prosecution
agreement once they do that
they can then. Well at whatever
stage they were in terms of
investigating the criminal
conduct that side. They could
pick that up right away. And if
let's say they were a week away
from filing- against excite.
They would be a week closer to
actually doing it today. That's
why we think it's important.
Given that once we are somewhat.
But we're a little bit
circumscribed what we can do
under the order because we got
to go through this dispute
resolution process we've added
the order was the- state
Attorney General it complies
with all due process
requirements. But that's- it
just takes longer for us get to
a point where can actually do
truth Forsman. With the US DOJ.
If they were drawn on
prosecution agreement. They can
move right for them to. But
what is the do part for the
different pieces designs
proceed with prosecution. Good
for on behalf of DOJ.
Prosecutor for violating the
orders in the agreements for
non compliance will so that
that's possible they didn't
when they signed the non
prosecution agreement- we don't
know the full totality of what
they were investigating- and
it's really up to them to bring
those charges that means the OJ
right. They were made. The
prosecution when the agreement
was signed. And so not remember
me yeah. Yeah but it it would
be picking that back when that
happens. Obviously there's the
potential for criminal
prosecution but certainly civil
a prosecution would allow for.
A potentially right a for more
funds to clean up the eighty
eighty community I would so I
would suspect. Not to mention
reimburse expenses. So it's
really up to DOJ how they
structure but it could- it has
certainly restructured non
prosecution agreements with
other entities that they've
entered into with waiting out
of five. The agreement to
require additional actions in
this case it would be up to DOJ
but surely could say. We will
only let you go this far if you
contribute action out of money.
And then it's negotiation
between those two entities.
Thank you. Our if the- non
prosecution agreement were to
be dropped are there risks
inherent in that to the TSA or
the state. The only see upside.
There were only upside we
didn't fact fact requested so
we think there's definitely
absent okay I. If ugh ugh you
could refer back to us like
twelve I have some questions
about the a to try and to. Just
rolled out a little bit and for
the system were better informed.
Of ten thousand one hundred and
fifty eight parcels that are
identified in the one point
seven miles all of. Area eighty
roughly five eleven ample. Is
the full extent of Sam. I think
that comes under the act. Right
if we get access to other-
other parcels we can continue
sampling so officers under
under it- parcels if I at
eighty five fifty five and
sixteen hundred. That and tell
on fifty. The close. Your cool
but it only does matter of. We
have a nasty to her so we don't
rely on a her for doing the
copies but- it would be useful
to know- what the you know what
what is represented by the
difference okay and how that
breaks down do you have none
the Silicon night. Okay we'll
get that to you. I and can I
just say one one thing about
that for those sixteen hundred
personals and the average. We
don't write anybody off until
we've gone through of really
exhaustive process. Of trying
to get in touch with them and
even then we still are open to
suggestions as to how to get a
little property members
property- owners and we're
talking about seven. Attempted
engagement in some cases and
that includes certified letters
and things like that. Just want
to point that out. And assembly
member Garcia if I subtract.
One thousand six of six and
sixteen hundred from eight
thousand five hundred and fifty
five. What. The. Eighty five
five five. That's all five okay
I've moved I'm- public thank
you for thank you for the
detail of- but but- what what
I'm what I'm getting at now is.
A we've sampled. Eighty five
eight thousand five hundred
fifty five parcels- cleaned
thousand center and six and
then there's another Cristina
we don't have access to. I
backing up estimate will by
housing how far off of my- a
little bit. So the so there's
around five thousand parcels
remaining- to be cleaned is
that right. What and how much
time we spent on the initial
phases. Of we started cleaning
when. Sir I just want to add in
one other factor not all the
properties are above eighty. So
there's some certain percentage
that are lesson. And I don't
have those numbers right off
the top of my head but I'll
I'll get them to you so what
I'm getting at- by going
through this exercise is trying
to get an understanding of.
Even with the efficiencies that
we're talking about here what's
the timeline look like going
forward. It's there's a couple
different ways to answer that I
don't want to insult the wrong
way so. In terms of. Keeping
our intent is just to maintain
the pace of work and as as as-
we mentioned the idea would be
to ramp up now that spring is
coming in to get more even more
than one hundred property stone
a month. So that's that's our
goal and you can just. We'll
just keep going until on we
don't have funds and then we'll
look for the other funds will
assume you have fun we have I'm
just from- from the first time
you have fun- what how much
work is left to be done. Zoom
to match the presumed workload.
What is the time frame. Of
let's suck- additional. Let
let's let's imagine at the
current pace. Is the future
place. Hundred fifty I'm trying
to give the folks here a sense
of. Where we are in time with
this project because I think
we're talking more than three
years. Three for four years.
Can not these are not numbers
that I think anybody should
hold you to it might take
longer right but hopefully your
wedding on strategies. To
actually reduce that time which
I think that's commendable and
a good idea- but yet. Another
three years or so certainly in
in the- communication with
members of- of the local
community who were affected-
you've identified a lot of
different. Means of
communication which I think is
great- but you haven't
mentioned texting which- to me
is one of the most obvious ways
of he met back folks out there
would you appreciate the
ability. To communicate back
and forth by taxed. But I know
I know you that much more than
email today- and I don't think
I'm exceptional in that so if
you could consider adding that
to the ways. In which you
communicate it might actually
be more efficient. Of and then
with respect to the- remaining
funds there's about ninety
million dollars left- in a best
case scenario. How much further
second take us. So it it
depends on a lot of different
factors- most notably depends
on whether we can get into you
know price contract. If you
take a house going to be my
next question. You know we have
two different contractors and
that's good because we want
each one to be able to ramp up-
to the number of cruise if they
can sustain- so that we can
clean up more properties
concurrently. You know roughly
if you take a look at the
ninety four million dollars
that remains. I think we can
get close to about twenty seven
hundred they're about. So about
half give or take a of the
remaining parcels and then
they'll be a need for
supplemental appropriation
yeah. Thank you for that. Are
there any other questions other
questions this Garcia. Yes
thank you. We have phase one of
was a goal of thirty two
hundred until at the rate at
which we're going we're not
going to have enough money from
the Appropriations we have
right now for face one we have
face to homes that are above.
Eighty and below four hundred
which is still a really high
level that need to be cleaned
up and so we have many home fix
that occurs a behind no one's
going to be left behind-
anything there's a lot of
confusion and the community
about. What that means for now
face one and even face to our
face the whatever the
additional basis we have here.
And while the- well we've
appropriate at this money. We
do have the potential for more
money seventy coming in through
two different bill for the
community has worked on the
battery fee fund us so that we
can see a future. I to make
sure that we were not leaving
homes behind can you speak to
that a little bit. Yeah so we
are looking and- at those bills
and what they mean in terms of
us. Prioritizing different
cleanups and- because that is a
statewide. Initiative however.
We recognize that this is an
ongoing clean up and first of
all as- as we talked about any
interruptions to the work
that's going on here will only
end up being more costly. And
so whatever we can do to
maintain the work and
continuity of the work and use
available funds were ever those
funds com the better off we're
going to be and so we're very
motivated to make sure the
other funds or- any other funds
that we- have a have a have
available to us can get used
honest. To again keep the crews
in the field keep the momentum
going and so what as we look at
the dollars that we do have we
talked about the Parsons
contract but we haven't talked
about the NEC contract and-
less I remember seeing that it
was a substantially lower cost
per household. Without contract
and to do can you speak to. Why
we have the disparities and if
there is separate to try to
expand the NEC contractor. Is
just trying to figure out the
discrepancy here and get the
most bang for our Buck. Yeah
over the life of the their
participation in the project in
the sea is rich in about sixty
eight thousand dollars per
parcel so substantially lower
than the eighty three for
persons we're in the midst of
finalizing an amendment and
then the number seven. To any
seize contract that will
provide additional partials-
because were we haven't yet
issued it we can't really speak
to the particulars in it that's
fine to say. That will contain
hundreds of properties- that we
believe- needs to be put into
place. Because they're just-
they cost less and do a really
good job. A cleaning up
partials relative to Parsons-
we still think it's good to
stick with to contractors
because once again we can have
more crews in the field. But in
terms of any see where we were
right on the cusp of reaching
them a new amendment. So once
we issue that and will become
public but it's going to
contain hundreds of properties.
So we're very motivated to give
them as much work as we can.
Quite simply. The news cycle a
single you know access question
every time we me with PTSD what
is it that we could do outside
of a- finances that we could do
because- if there are. Problems
with- contracting that prevent
you from sole sourcing and it's
not my prog who does the work
it's my proud of that. That
it's done in a quick as to and-
highest quality. Are there
impediments that need to be
changed legislatively that
would. Allow offer a quick
quicker faster more efficient
clean up. Yeah at this point-
just referencing back to one of
my earlier statements. Of this
being a large complex project-
having contractors understand.
The difficulties of
implementing it we want to get
them wrapped up as quickly as
possible and that's really the
most important thing. There are
other cost reduction measures
and we work with your staff and
other staff for- other-
legislators with local
governments to try and
streamlined reduce permitting
costs for example- we're
talking about ways in which we
can work with a local
governments to do our reach to
some of the either sixteen
hundred properties are people
who are. Really responsive. I
think holding hearings like
this that- are publicized in
the get the word out to people
who might not. It's amazing but
it's true that they might not
know about okay that that
letter that I got release they
should call that number- it's
really the accumulation of all
these actions within these
communities that helps us- make
certain we gotta properties to
clean up. And I really don't
think that the that legislative
statutory. Impediments are
really getting our progress on
the on the project and for all.
I think we've learned a lot
more much more efficient. As it
is we'll continue to work on
that but right now I don't
think that's where our focus.
Well Greta- I want to thank
you- director Williams and-
deputy director call for the-
presentations this evening and
to hope- one or both of you
will be able to stick around
for the public comment to.
Becoming a long after our next
panel. So thank you get it out
I would like to invite to our
speakers for the second panel
supervisor Hilda so lease. Okay.
I'm and we were expecting that
Dr- barber for rare of the LA
county department of public
health and unfortunately she
was not able to attend who was
called away on other business-
but we are very fortunate to
have your doctor Cyrus Rankin
in her place. There's right end
up please remember if you want
to make public comment which
will happen at the end of this
panel- got a card from a one of
the folks who are. Roaming
about in the auditorium and
hold hold those cards up high
so that other people can.
Either retrieve them like this
individual here- or you can get
one. There you go. Thank you-
supervisors police said thank
you assembly member bloom and
the subcommittee number three
and one of congratulate you
again for having this very
important hearing tonight and
also for the assembly members
Cristina Garcia and Mister
Santiago- who I know are have
been very deeply engaged in
this issue want to thank you
and I want to thank the
residents almost feel like
asking people to stand up and
just kinda. You know shake
yourself a little bit because
this is a very very- serious
discussion we're having and
what he's saying that because I
want people to kind of bills
off there's a lot of
information and- obviously it's
a Friday evening there's a lot
happening in the county of Los
Angeles and I do want to make
clear that- our director for
public health stuff to buy
refer couldn't be here tonight
because we another- fascinating.
How can I say challenge that's
facing the county if not- the
entire. Continent and that is
has to do with this- virus a
corona virus so we're dealing
with that right now and have
been this morning but we're
here today and I'm I will again
want to thank you for your time
and effort. Assembly member
bloom for providing this
opportunity to hear from the
community I know. That's first
and foremost what this is about
really to hear from the
constituents and I wanna give a
shout out to well. Colorado
who's the before he leaves. And
also to all the stakeholders in
the community residents in the
people that have been impacted
for the so many years of that
this is been an ongoing-
challenge for us here in in-
the one point seven mile radius
but if not. Perhaps even
farther than that more than the
ten thousand households that
have been impacted I think
there has been a lot of
progress made I kind of one of
begin on that no because I have
seen- the difference in terms.
At least attention being paid.
In just a brief discussion that
I had was father- John read
earlier he tells me that
there's been a series of other
meetings. Just this week. With
a kißm de and DTS see staff
that have been here. And that
that gives me some sense that
people are finally really
taking this- very seriously and
at a level that we have not
seen before- and I think it has
to do a lot with their
constituents in the residents
making their voices heard. But
also along with the leadership
now in the state. In the
assembly- three year leadership
and yet this committee staff in
the members that are. Seated
here and also- I would say- are
governor both governor's
previous governor Jerry Brown
who initially gave us some
funding- to start this- knowing
full well that that was just
the first step. And I think
with this- new governor Gavin
Newsom these- in a unique.
Position I think to help us out
even more and I've seen it
demonstrated already through.
The passage of legislation that
Dahle. Name address are simply
woman care. I know that to a
lot of lifting on the part of
the community and people here
in the room- and trying to
figure out how those those
funds are going to come to this
community knowing that that
legislation. Impacts the entire
state but certainly this is one
of those areas we hope that.
Those funds could be- utilized
quickly so that whatever
mechanisms and formulas that
are set up that we look at-
income in low income areas that
are in distress right now and
if the pace that. Of we just
learned- that it will take to
clean up to get to the other
six thousand or so households
it's going to take some time.
So I know I understand that
we're going to need a lot a lot
more help here. I understood
initially that we were the TSC.
In two thousand eight was
targeting households of at
least two thousand five
hundred. And I just heard I
think here that there that was
now of up. To three thousand.
Three thousand thirty five
hundred which is which is
great- but I know our goal is
to really. Attempt to reach
more households- I'm happy that
the governor's budget included
the seventy four. Of point five
million this year and that was
we want to thank the governor
for that. Well that's money
that I believe- can help us- in
a small way to understand and
hopefully get more teams out
work crews out. On on the field
and in the ground to help
provide the cleanup but I'm
very excited about AB one forty
two because I know that that
money. Is going to provide
relief over time for many many
years to come so I we want to
work with the DTS see. And with
our partners to see how we can
try to expedite that- I am a
little bit concerned about the
fact it of. Fees regarding
other regulatory agencies as
appeared in the presentation
may have some impact perhaps
there's a way that we can work
with those agencies also. To
understand. The difference in
the magnitude. Of the problem
that we're facing here. And to
work with us I know that there
been other remedies in other
parts of the state. And perhaps
that can also be something in
terms of legislative.
Initiative to bring forward
that concern to those agencies
it also receives state funding.
And perhaps there may be some
mechanism for they can also
provide relief- the deal with
heavy trucks for example a
ki<c.cyan> de. Of things of that</c>
nature- just in terms of fees
that are administered. Perhaps
there's a some waivers or
something that could be looked
at- one thing that I do wanna
addresses that. The sixteen
hundred- households where we've
not been able I think the TSC
have been able to contact the
land. Landlords appropriately I
think our county we may be in a
position to try to help.
Identify who those property
owners. Bar treasurer tax
collector. And perhaps that's
something that we can work on I
think I mentioned that earlier
to. To Meredith. At a meeting I
had with yesterday- in other
words counties ready ready and
willing to work and I think
we've demonstrated that. I'm
very I'm very pleased that-
initially we put in our own two
million dollars just to do our
own testing. And to come back
and to share that with the
previous- DTS see director in
terms of how this could be
quickly expedited. And I really
want to give kudos to Dr barber
for were. Ferrer who was in
here but our staff is. Very AB
able to describe- with that has
entailed and I do wanna let the
community know and I think many
of them. Present here know that
we really took this very
serious. At the county of Los
Angeles where it we actually
had our stay. Only tear and-
from Munich about in actually
help a survey. Five and homes.
Under to that cost we did. Our
and we're still. To out and
with that also. Prepared to put.
More on the tester. Today we
have the outside is providing
that would be doing the- since
we started. And that's also
Acosta spinning by the county
were we're glad to provide that
we know we have to do more
because you're still. Many
residents that are very
reluctant to come forward they
don't actually. At all times
understand what that means. But
we try think in fact to get
back to them as soon as
possible there are. Some of
alarms they go off so that they
know what actions to take and
how we can help remedy that.
And we do have clinics
available here one that was
just opened about two years ago
and son son all east LA. Clinic
that's available just to do
testing and I think. The your
your committee some of the
members went out when you were
last here. So I wanna I wanna
you know just remind you of
that. I think a in terms of
what. We're trying to do is
really- we've together other
sources of funding that we
have. We were able to secure
funding- through Dealey so can
you canyon settlement. Of five
million dollars and we were
able to set aside. To help us
for cleanup so we set up a
special- how can I say a
process to be able to use and
drawn up money to help is here
with excite. So we've been
pulling monies aside in any way
that we can. In addition- to
our- lead based paint hazardous
remediation program we've also.
A look to providing of and how
can I say partnership with the
TNC to start looking at how we
can overlay the same households
or- at least not or duplicate
but try to reach a far greater
number. Of households to begin
that cleanup so we appreciate
the funding that. That we
received from the state- and
through all of. Department of
housing and urban development
where they awarded as three
point four million dollars but
keep in mind that isn't just
for the exciting packed it
area. So we have to negotiate
as you know with other- board
members so we are we are
dealing with that but our
highest priority has always
been areas where have. They
have been heavily contaminated
so we're going to continue to
do that so in addition to that
were also again looking at a
settlement that we had with the
California Attorney General. LA
county and the city of LA a
hundred and twenty million
dollars settlement- with regard
to Porter Porter ranch. So that
will also I believe assistance
in some manner and again- this
is not been an easy. Process
for us because other entities
local governments don't think
that the county should have
been given. Us some of that
settlement but we argued I
think pretty effectively and
that matter and that's where we
can also use help so that our
state partners understand that
were also using new- measures-
to try to extract in and
receive funding here what we
believe. Funding can be
utilized in a manner that still
conforms with cleanup so Lisa
canyon yes very important. I
very important how can we of.
That additional funding do more
and work together with the
state and with our other local
entities to see that that. That
that happens- I wanted to just
tell you that I know our
constituents as to has been
articulated by the assembly.
Individuals seems to. Ring ring
true and that people are still
very concerned about why is it
taking so long. To get their
homes cleaned up. And one of
the things that- we've learned
also is it once people do have
their homes clean. How are they
made aware that the clean up is
actually- verified- and if
someone is coming back right
and I know that maybe the
protocols aren't set in place
for that. But perhaps there can
be made some assurances
whatever that measurement is
the people fully understand
that in layman's terms. So I
really do believe communication
I think is going to be a theme
you're going to keep hearing
about. Because while things are
happening on the ground with
the cruise a clean up it's
always about the communication
and the cultural competency.
And the cultural competency
comes through in terms of the
contracting. The people that
are on the ground and your
staff fifty TSC but more
importantly I also think that
it's important for us to think
about how we can. Probably help
to bridge this miscommunication
by having another set of eyes
and I know that you have groups
now that you're contracting
with the east side yards. But I
would like to suggested perhaps
there's a way that other groups
community groups are already
doing this kind of work.
Reaching out to the same people
whether it even be on census
for example people are knocking
on doors for different things
now. Perhaps carrying
information along with that
effort about what people might
know or not know about what's
happening with that side. And
what that means so if there's a
way that we can try to
collaborate or create some form
of funding that can be made
available to those- third party
groups but our vested here and
have the credit the
credentials. The credibility I
think that that could be
something that should be looked
at and whether you pull that
from DTS see or from-
department of. Health could
probably be a way of maybe-
bringing that together I know
we've been able to couple for
funding. Streams together
through a pull health. To do.
That very same our so I don't
see why the state couldn't
explore. Some new avenues to
try to try to bring on more-
more staff that are capable of
doing that- I would just say
the other thing is. I think I
think we ought to really
explore what- what is happened
with respect to- excite not
being in compliance. With the
TSC and DOJ- I know our county
council we've had those
discussions. And were more than
happy to work. Alongside with
you. The TSC in the state to
see how we can leverage that.
So we can try to get more for
our residents here because I
believe me in my opinion
personally speaking. As a
collected official I would have
never settle for. For this
agreement additionally and I
think that I think that's
really important- just to say
with that. We have some very
able able and capable people
here- will speak in more detail
about some of the questions
with- the particulars of what
we've been doing but I do want
to keep keep you are fully
aware that. You know we
represent- East Los Angeles
mostly heavily impacted here
but the other cities that have
been impacted bill commerce-
burn in. A may would. This del
all all of them deserve to have
the same level of the-
treatment in terms of getting
information out there are no a
series of meetings have been
help. Make you need to happen
with the cities but I do think
that. A crew has to be made
available that will be able to
articulate. With the various
cities also in explaining
because we often get calls. Of
from some of our local
residents that we represent in
those areas as well that
sometimes the information is
not. Is not given in an
appropriate consistent
consistent manner and I would
ask that more meetings be
health. Of a on a smaller scale
so that smaller cities and
groups can come together and
understand and they're looking
at. Apples to apples and- that
that it that- that we get some
feedback about how that is
being conducted- and just
lastly I'm happy that. I'm
happy that we have a new
director at the TSC- but I am
too concerned about the two
contracts. Of more importantly
with Parsons in anything
because I think there can be
some. Cost savings in terms of
contracting and- trying to
lower lower any administrative-
or other costs- and looking at
how we can open up
opportunities perhaps with
other contractors. And really
see in- you know the best the
quality but also looking ahead
in terms of workforce because
right now we have competing
interests in terms of who is
capable of clean up. And many
of those individuals are
working on some of our
construction projects as we
speak now. In terms of
retrofitting housing that we
need because we have an urgency
with homelessness. So we're
pulling from the same pool so
we need to grow the pool so I
would ask that. The state also
look at using some of those
workforce training dollars that
you have that the governor's
put in his budget. To set aside
in can- for projects like this
where where we find a shortage
of individuals that are
available in perhaps as a pipe
effort maybe look at. Of places
that have been- impacted
because of health and other
issues that are I know are of
great concern to our governor.
So with that- I would just
leave leave you with that and
thank you for the opportunity
to be here and to thank the
residents. And everybody that
has been working so hard- the
fight goes on. Is what I would
say. In the fight because on
and we have to. Keep our eye on
goal. Thank and because about
it so with that I wanted to do
so doctor still be opening at
the who's here. She's the
regional health officer first
boss seven which we are in
which includes east LA
southeast LA and the exite.
Impacted area would turn it
over to her and her staff.
Thank you thank you thank you
very much for those comments-
and to for your on going
interests and- truly a
dedication on on this issue and
you have a lot of. The
expressed a lot of comments-
concerns and ideas I think
they're all. Of consideration
and- looking forward to the-
next presentation. I'm sorry we
don't have name cards for all
of the show we have a very
professionally done one for a
doctor Russian. Mister chair on
behalf of doctor Ferreira
director Valley county public
health I want to thank you for
inviting me here tonight. I
want to thank you for the work
that you've done on this
important issue as it directly
impacts the health and well
being of thousands of Los
Angeles county residents face.
A continuing risk of exposure
to lead contaminated soil on
their own properties. But I
also want to thank and
acknowledge the work of
supervisors so release on this
issue. Under her leadership LA
county has undertaken
significant efforts to. Secure
funding for the investigation
and cleanup of that
contaminated communities
impacted by Exide technologies.
Battery recycling in Vernon. I
want to thank the community for
your- of continue demands for
expedited cleaning up all
exterior contaminated lands and
for the- cleanup of the
interior of homes. As requested
by community members we have
expanded services in the
community. We offer blood test
as was mentioned- previously at
a lot of locations and
functions in that are- go- are
available here. Tonight as well
as in our on health center on
Sunland the supervisor mention.
We are also expanding the
capacity of the local health
care providers to screen young
children for developmental
delays and to connect. The
affected families to needed
services at their local schools.
In just a in- to say something
in Spanish KT yeah I mean this
and then landed us yes us but
we soda force who needed asco
in a stable that phone those
pada. A misty Gatling get level
meaning that point I mean now
the board. Four nine three
seven eight technology. Yelled
at hero and now have to. Turn
it over to Dr Rangan. Of the
medical texts. Toxicologist
with environmental health by LA
county. Thank you very much-
Dodge creative- I wanted ext
also extend my thanks to the
assembly members for putting
this together and helping to
sort of shepherd this whole
thing through the state all in
all of the work the really
gives us the starting point say
where we can do. Our work and
also to supervisors Lisa you in
the members of your office that
really- keep health as the
front of the line issue and
despite all the- work that all
of our elected officials are
doing on the regulatory
frontier in the contracting in
the finance and the legal
issues- we are all here for one
primary reason. And that's
that's our health and
everything else is supporting
the port of that- and- new- Mr
Garcia made a an important
point about you know trying to
see how we can all put our
heads together about doing
things faster- because this is
not just an important issue in
public health isn't urgent
issue in public health and is
the urgency. For me that- you
really sort of resonates about
this whole situation we need to
always continually look for
ways and sit back broadly and
put our heads together to try
to figure out how can we do
this faster and I know there's
probably ways that we haven't
thought of yet. And we need to
continue to do that- all that
being said- I think what's
important result in a in a lot
of what I'm saying I've said
before it many public meetings
I think it's always good to
remind ourselves about the
importance of this health issue
here. We learned a lot in the
past twenty or thirty years
about how human health is very
tied to our to our environments
and we always knew that but now
we know a lot more about it-
than we ever did and when you
look at the contamination that
excite has rained down on this
community not just for the past
ten years twenty years thirty
years but for the past. Eighty
to ninety years- and we have-
so much contamination that has-
impacted this. Just bear but
also on the ground as a result
of that it's just an atrocious
situation when it comes to can
unity contaminate. It and then.
How for decades I'm sure every
knows this room Exide operated
without a permit and because
they were operating without a
permit we have a significant
lack of data all the emissions
that may have been occurring
over the past many decades and
so we don't have- the ability
to truly estimate. The impacts
of all of those chemicals over
all those years over all of
your lives and that's very
unfortunate so what that puts
us the position that puts us in
in the health department is
that we have to take what we
know now and try to provide
services and resources for you
moving forward in order to make
sure that your health is
maintained and you can live as
healthy lives as possible- when
it comes to. Lead contamination
in particular which is what
we're talking about today there
are multiple sources of lead in
our environment we've known
this for a very long time even
in this bottle if you look hard
enough there's a little bit of
light in there we know that we
are exposed to lead in small
amounts from many different
sources- one of the primary
sources as many of us are where
are is lead paint that is in
many homes. But when it comes
to community like like this
that communities that live near
the exite facility you now have
this extra layer of unique and
obviously unnecessary
contamination and it's right in
your front yards in your
backyard so if you're homes.
And that is a very very unique
kind of potential exposure to
lead that you have that the
other folks in the rest of Los
Angeles county don't have as
supervisors Lee said we have
our our our- our our truck
outside where you can get free
let testing. We do that around
these communities there's one
other area where we do that as
well that's the communities
around Gwinnett co big surprise
right and we don't really have
that service in most of the
rest of Los Angeles county
because they don't need it as
much as he's communities need
it. And you're gonna need that
service for the foreseeable
future and until all this
contamination has been taken
care of until all the homes are.
Seen that Sir is going to have
to be there and that's what I
want to come of you know
highlights is as the goal I
want to eliminate that service.
I want to get to the point
where we don't have to have
that service anymore. And once
we get to the point where all
the homes are clean we're one
step closer to that. So when it
comes to exposure to lead
exposure to lead can cause a
number of different problems.
But there are some twists and
turns about that but I want to
kind of talk to you about. We
know that led can affect
multiple body systems we know
it can affect your kidneys we
know can affect your liver we
know can affect your brain. And
a number of other organs in our
body- but you the way that led
works. It's a little bit like.
Like having high blood
pressure. Here's what I mean by
that. If you look at a person
who has high blood pressure you
can't look at them and just
kind of know. That person has
high blood pressure. High blood
pressure is one of those will
be called silent diseases where
people can have it for a long
time and longer you have it the
longer you have it. The more it
affects your body and then
later on you start to have-
real issues heart disease.
Stroke a risk all kinds of
problems like that. Latest kind
of the same way you can have
letting your body and the more
that you have a risk of being
exposed to it and the more let
that builds up in your body
over time. He can be very very
silent and then as soon as you
get to a point. Enough lead in
your body. A lot of bad things.
But and those bad things and-
they're very hard to reverse.
So that's why we want to make
sure that whenever we are
dealing with lead exposure for
lead poisoning. The most
important thing about that is
preventing it to begin with
because once it already happens
it's very hard to- put the
toothpaste back in the tube
right that's the sort of the
way that we look at it. So
prevention is what it's all
about and the way that we can
prevent more lead poisoning is
by clean these are is to
prevent that exposure. When
children go outside and play.
Yeah whether we like it or not
children eat about one to two
tablespoons of dirt on a per
day when they're playing
outside. As a as a your plane
looking their hands in
accumulated that it's about one
to two tables and that's what
the estimate is. And the
children in the playoffs. If
they're there should be a
reason why children can't play.
Outside in your front yard in
the backyard and your neighbors
yards. And so to have a
situation like this where. You
now basically can't live a
normal life. Right have your
children play outside- that's a
big deal to us and so clean
these homes is not just about-
the strictly the health issue
of lead poisoning but it's
about your general likelihood.
And that's why it's important
issue to us of the public
health department. So the
response the seizure of course
requires very pollution cleanup
of all these properties. And
the allocation of funding
necessary in order to make that
happen. Now young children and
families were exposed to
hazardous chemicals over long
periods of time whether it's
that. Or something else brings
up a lot of issues in terms of
the services that we as a
public health department. Need
to make sure that you have
available. And so want to talk
a little bit about some of the
services that we're making
available have made available
to the community and we're
still working on as well. The
first is to make sure that we
insure. That there is good
enough- access to information
and into services. As the
supervisor said we've got you
know a few- local- department
of health services
comprehensive health centers.
That are in this area those are
made available to residents to
receive- free helps at this
health services in general and
also free let let screening.
And then financial screening as
well for your family to
evaluate- where you can fit in
with health insurance etcetera.
And also this permanent- county
resource center that was
established to provide support.
And information for the
community as well let let
screening as was mentioned to.
And other resources as well to-
the residents around the exite
facility- it's also important
to us to link the community
residents to healthcare
resources. Particular to that
free blood led screen it's want
to talk a little bit more about
that as well. Since about- two
thousand sixteen or so- we were
offering but let's be a little
bit before that but it really
started to take shape around
two thousand sixteen. Since
that time we three to six
thousand residents so far who'd
been had a blood lead tests-
through those efforts.
Including four thousand. And
that's just the F. that were
talk about the three blocks
screening. Dish to help
provider who are. Doing let's
screening is a- yeah are to. Is
refer lots family as well the-
to provide to. A may this test
as well. That's we improve the
Gen away. But I also wanted a
highlight the- the community
outreach that- that we've taken
on as well. As supervisor said
we've had a lot of different
outreach campaigns that we've
been engaged in since around
two thousand fifteen. Around
the time when the facility was
closing- to inform residents
about contamination on their
properties. How to protect
themselves in their home- about
the efforts that the state is
undertaking as well and the
importance of blood lead
testing- and in addition member
it this is. Not only about lead
right there are some other
chemicals had this facility-
released into the environment
as well. A number of different
gases and all of these
chemicals have raised your-
risk of long term health
effects so it's not. Only about
let it's about other chemicals
to and so we're- engage in
efforts to educate you and also
your healthcare providers about
all the things that could be
occurring. As a result of those
exposures. Supervisor also
mention the survey- that we did
in two thousand seventeen. And
altogether after those outreach
efforts in the survey efforts
and more door to door efforts
we actually reach about sixteen
thousand homes all together
now- to- provide. Our region
and link residents to the
health services sat through
resource tables etcetera we
have a number community events
that we do at. A church in
community centers YMCAs and
number rather different places.
And for more details on that we
have our table outside and you
can- go to them they'll be able
to tell you- more places that
you can- I'll go for not. Let
testing but just to get the
more resources and get that
letter sometime today you want
or you. Talk to our folks out
there you can such but to it
at. An early time and I think
we have we've done all a
hundred of those can. Outreach
event we plan do a lot more.
When I get back to hell care
for. As well because it's not
only. Edge you about these but
also your care. In this. So
that they aware about what to
out for and- the- are as I said
because of the lack of. Data
that we don't have over the
last eighty ninety years about
emissions that came from
excite. It's hard to really put
a number on the risks that
people have we know that your
risks of. Long term illnesses
are elevated but knowing
exactly how much is something
we may never know the answer
to. That's why it's important
to make sure your healthcare
providers are armed with the
information to know. How should
they be regarding U. S.
patients what kinds of
screenings are more important
to do for you as you age. To
make sure that we- catch
disease early in prevent them
from happening if possible. So
we have been connecting with
the- with healthcare leaders so
all over the area. And met with
about two hundred. Said that.
In in the area but we it about
proxy for. Miles of X. working.
To efforts to a- of. About X.
in general. How the health care
needs of the as red. And when
receive a- treatment when they-
obviously again to. Ever the
need for- for lead. Led screen.
And we develop materials for
them and resources for them to
call us when they have-
questions to- again you know we
do all this stuff because we
know the necessity of the it
especially for this. Particular
community and the- the issues
that you've gone through the
experiences you that you've had
as a result of this
contamination. And again my
vision is I want to get to a
point where we do not have to
have. That truck out there to
screen people for let it's
great that we have it's great
to have that resource for. All
you. The bill seat. Stand your
blood leads us. But would great
if we to that point where we-
clean up all these your- and
got rid of. All and would have
need for that anymore that's-
the world I want. To an- and
getting the done as quick as-
is the first so with that.
Wanted now. To not allow of our
head. Next Janet Scully. And
she me talk a little bit about
our account. Of and resources
the we are at to. A number
these different efforts so.
Turned over to a T. Janet. And
we're gonna but and wrap
separate. To eight thirty and
still want to have time the
people who was like. Up to a-
as a think we've got a half
dozen or so. Rick just. So
within that time I will put the
red things up for public. So
it's a two about the exciting.
The county used fund we see
from the way. Say that. To
educate. And learning to.
Assessed for two. Live in the-
impacted by. And so public
health actually pie. A pro. To
in. Development screening. And
all families to. So that
healthcare providers can I de.
Per early. And initiate ness in
other nest. Interventions and
then I'm really excited to
announce that the county
receive funding to provide-
lead paint hazard remediation.
So and other home improve
service to. Homes the exite
area and as supervisor so least
mentioned- I won't go into
detail but we recieved. And two
of sources of funding to do
lead paint hazard remediation
in this community we've already
begun the work it's going very
well- we have a table outside
and with folks who can give you
more information or you can.
Fill out an application and see
if your your home qualifies. I
also just wanted to mention
that the county received
approximately a hundred and
thirty four million dollars as
the result of a twenty year
hard fought lawsuit with three
paint companies. And this
funding will allow us to launch
an unprecedented and county
wide program to provide lead
paint hazard remediation
services. And that's scheduled
to start in April twenty twenty
and that will also include the
exciting area this program will
consist of community outreach
blood lead testing- lead paint
hazard assessment and
remediation this kind of work
has never been done to this
size or this go. Anywhere else
in the country so with the
trail Blazers for this work- so
thank you for allowing us to
speak- public health really
enjoys working is in this
community even given the
circumstances we enjoyed
meeting you we enjoy working
with you- we've had really
great experiences here. And we
hope to continue working really
hard for this community- with
that I wanted to let you know
we have a short video and it
really describes the lead paint
repair services that are now
being offered- again these are
free services no cost to you
and we thought this is just a
really nice- demonstration of
what you can expect. I see a
blank in the sky. Which in this.
He won't. Nay or stop. Darkness
or- have reached home and my
some born couple my after we
didn't know was a in anything
like that but when I him to get
tested that came out positive
his finger and then when he
went and got his blood work
completely that and I told me
it was it was like a half an
I've I was a cover I have
someone relief because a it's
carried know your has some in
your aware it. Either also came
when I. Also what color feet
which is like for your home.
And I think that's very
important because it take into
consideration our names tend.
To you know make it our home
because it is our home so we
have to make sure that we're
happy with the services that
your house. Is up to call their
house is safe and their houses
comfortable because you to live
in it. I see Lara mono. See I
have a- level yeah lead can be
a very silent please and you
can be exposed to lead you
convene poison lead and appear
or look healthy for some time
until those symptoms start to
appear so it's important for
parents to know that even
though your children me looking
if you're healthy now they
could be incurring lead
exposure in those homes and
addressing that issue is
extremely important to do now
to avoid problems later. This
definitely sets the stage the
allocation of these funds to
address lead paint in homes is
unprecedented. And to do the
number of homes in the time
period that we're going to do
them it's going to set a
tremendous example for the rest
of the country. We targeted
those particular areas because
these are areas that we know
have a lot of old housing stock
and we know that this is an
under represented population as
well. One of the most common
ways to address lead paint in
homes was assembly paint over
it but this is a comprehensive
way to get the lead paint out
of office and to renovate them
to the point where lead is no
longer risk to the structure.
My parents have lived here for.
Thirty three years so the have
been offering to remove the
pain that. May contain less and
hopefully that can be of good
to our nieces and nephews to
actually come in this of the
house. And our cousins who are
actually pregnant so you know I
know that that's pretty
hazardous for their house. I'm
glad that they came and offered
like. More more information
about it. You see all this. Hi
highlighter. Those are the ones
are interested. But I'm a
little for the acre goodness
will be implicated the three
most common as well say Los a
automotive Chen us get benefit
us us and giving an insight on
this because you. Number zero
one zero down. Who is that I
guess we're going to build
before today either well give
you a quick demo on some of the
tools are going to use that are
using I'm not to get her all
and as a result of training
these experts in order to go
into homes and not only do the
deconstruction reconstruction
but to specifically address the
idea that lead paint is a
hazard to young children and to
the people of those households.
This creates a new work force
and new workforce it's able to
go into these homes and not
only address the problems of
renovation of the problems of
lackey. When my idea of fun
nation. Or what the Downey
program came. And we started
doing the lead mitigation on
the paint. I love the neighbors
star a like kind of being
curious and asking questions
how can I get my housing to the
program. When we talk to our
neighbors or we're always like
quick to say like. Oh by the
way. You know your house is in
the contaminated area you
should. Contact this lesion
long online. This effort is not
only designed to renovate
individual homes but it is
designed to renovate entire
neighborhoods it's not
something that people should
simply have to live with this
is something that should be
addressed as comprehensively as
possible to get that let him
out. And to have a life free
help. You know when you see
something. And see it happen
then you know you can hear more
yak nine find out as opposed to
someone just telling you. But
then you know you. Get senior
in India. Now from our initial
thoughts of. Yeah know a that
going to have. And then. You
know and actually did. Well
thank you for that thank you
for all the reasons tions and
John we will move on to public
comment now- I did receive one.
A card that has the comment
written on it and I think it's
a Clara cation a request for
clarification that's an
important one it is from-
Martha Jimenez who is with the
excited vice re committee- and-
city terrace. United at request
clarification- for everyone- a
by DTS see- and I think it
expresses a misunderstanding-
about- the- non prosecution
agreement- so what I will I
want to- make sure that we're
clear about this. And if either
doctor Williams at director
Williams or a director- deputy
director coke want to address
this further than a statement
I'll make right now please do
so and correct me if I'm wrong.
But the non prosecution
agreement- does not mean that
excite is being let off the
hook. Quite the contrary- right
now the federal government has
entered into an agreement that
says we won't prosecute Exide
for crimes the non the if we
get rid of the non prosecution
agreement then Exide can be
current prosecuted for the acts
that they've committed whatever
they might be charged with by
the federal government. So it
actually. Has the effect of
creating additional liability-
not less is that essentially
accurate. So hopefully that to
clear that up but it's a very
important clarification- and
to- I'm glad that you asked the
question if there's any
confusion out there- sore first
up public comment if you'd like
to step four would come from-
Jane Williams and then will
follow that with Joe Gonzalez.
And senior John. Thanks for
being here. I'm James I'm the
executive director of
California communities toxics
and- I brought my excited file
in a read it here on the train
down in my file I had the notes
from my meeting with secretary
right Regus now almost five
years ago. Which had the
original agreement in it or the
clean up of excitement and the
closure. A that was. Well less
than fifty million dollars now
the cleanup is expected to cost
most of billion dollars and
take at least ten years. We are
still not prepared for the
magnitude of this clean up-
despite passing the to better
if you bills- we are
desperately in need of the same
things that we talked about
when we had this oversight
hearing last year which was we
need a long term save. Agency
because the clean up the
details he is running. Fraught
with problems and that such a
that. For your still has not
been able to get a copy if. The
legislature can get
accountability from the agency
but I would say that the các
members you have who are here
in the audience have kind of
lost hope. So ever the Lech.
They're trying to fix that
problem back there. Keep your.
Uhhuh uhhuh uhhuh push the
button on the base. Yeah okay.
So this is this is not
something this is not the
problem that we have with ex I
clean up is not gonna go away
we'll be here next year will be
here next year will be here
next year. Will be here next
year. We still don't have
enough money. Even with the
battery fee and we don't have
the kind of accountability from
the agency that we need to my
recommendation to the
legislature last year was to
create a long term stable
source of funding. We were able
to get forty million a year
through the battery she you can
see that that's probably not
going to be enough. On because
there's gonna be other
pressures on the fee as well.
And we cannot get
accountability from do TSC- I
understand the you know the
real reform package but I don't
think that anybody who's
watching the agency as long as
I have been. Or other folks
have been watching it in the
last five years things that and
oversight- board is going to
solve the exite problem. So I
leave you with that. I wish I
had a different. Recommendation
for you. And we definitely will
support the audit the
Assemblymembers Thiago is
asking for. Thank you for a
comma. A next up we have Joe
Gonzalez. Welcome good evening-
thank you all for attending I
really appreciate this we need
more meetings like this we it's
really really hard to squeeze
ugh eight nine years of battle
into a couple of minutes- I
want to thank especially
supervised release one of the
heroes of are. Contaminated
issue here that we're going
through and- hopefully we can
get more funding to the public
that the PH we need this
additional funnies we can
extend the kind of testing so
we can find out what this is
that we're actually feeling as
you see this used to be my-
day. These are health field
medical tag from the last two
years only and this is about
only half of the stuff that
I've gone through as far as
radiation treatments
chemotherapy MRI scans of
everything that that comes
along with being contaminated
and poisoned by this stuff
here- like doctor Rangoon was
saying was weekend. It's hard
to do a judge exactly what we
have been going through but we
need more no well unless we
have more so we can get like
say the bone studies or
something like this we don't
really know what we're facing
in and the we need more
appropriations from this.
Committee here okay. What need.
Is a thing that kind of. Angers
frustrates more for. I get any
about this because I dying any.
But the in frustrates me is
that we keep hearing or DTS see
talk about. All we cling to
thousand homes only cleaned up
two thousand three thousand all
of the old. It's kind of like
you trying to get some sort of
hysteria but all good you are
the bottom line the truth is
you have a clean up one single.
Because of I just do like this.
Doesn't mean the entire stages
clean. They haven't cleaned the
attics. It took a long time for
them to try to clean the
parkways. And the fact of the
matter is that. We made test. A
parkway. That need remediation
but not a whole. That doesn't
make sense we don't have a good
plan- PTSD is letting us down
tremendously. They do not have.
An expedient nor efficient
plan. We're talking about where
the cuts the often and ways to
cut costs. The easiest simplest
long ago asked of them we ask
them to do if you do a block by
block you sweep. If you're
gonna do a partial here and a
partial there when you talk
about individual parcels.
Arsenal turns into entire block
you're talking about more
efficiently spending this
money. You're talking about
cleaning this right the first
time not having to come back
again a second or maybe a third
time. Yeah. Wait what we need
is we need some oversight on
this too I mean it we have. I
think was I forget what the
number was it came from the
state we have a couple of
million also the came from the
county. We have the battery tax
which this community is really
really upset these communities
are really really upset that
battery tax was a- imposing
created so that we can address
the exite. But yet we're being
told that this some of this
money is going to go outside.
Up north in all these other
areas like this and- in I don't
have a problem with that if we
can clean up our mess your
first. Okay this is the public
health crisis I don't
understand what the deal is
were. We're trying to say well
we can't get into that
property- we can't- get this
person permission. Is a public
health crisis. Nobody has my
neighbor does not have a right.
To get me the kids or anybody
else sec. But leaving their-
amination. To a point where it
can flow into my- property. And
get me or my good for the
children sick. You know so I'm
trying to follow the de.
Stories that they're giving us
about pro high priority homes.
The high priority holding came
out about seven years ago. Up
and it was addressed to
pregnant women. And children
under five. I guarantee you
there's nobody who was seven
years ago pregnant is no longer
pregnant- and are still
pregnant I should say. And
there's no children don't
children that were under five
they're still under five seven
from seven years ago. And this
is the story that we're facing
every single day were not
getting. Real facts from our
from our of the TS in you
talked about text messaging.
I'll take that I mean just let
me know. There's nobody who has
been to more meetings I don't
think to myself. You know
concert in the TNC concerning
excite. And stuff like that I
think I missed one when I was
really out of one of my cancer
episodes. And up. I think all
together in all the- nine years
ten years we're fighting this.
I've gotten like maybe. Two or
three. Letters to my home.
Regarding meetings and stuff
like that everything else I
have to go out there and put
you know footwork. Look for the
stuff we're not getting the
stuff. And what also gets me
too is we don't have the P. S.
A.'s that we need we need
something. We don't have to
point a finger. Right an
exciting perhaps you know put
some sort of liability into the
county or- state or something
like that are. You know miss
something that this up right
there. But we do have to let
the- know. That what we facing
we go home. What what the kids
are facing when they walk to
school back to school what's
out of playing the yard and
stuff like that. We need to let
the people know how to take
care of themselves. We didn't
we need to let them know that
there's a danger. We have had
many family that have moved
into the neighborhood. Thinking
they were going to. You know
have the American dream. Reyes
a vampire home raise a family.
And live the American dream you
know. So your child play
baseball and- graduated from
high school walking down the
aisle stuff like that. But yet
unfortunately what's happened
is many many families here. And
if we have a few families are
just recently of with moved in
the neighborhoods. You don't
know a thing about what's going
on. And their children were
coming up. Here learning
disabilities and stuff like
this we know there's a lot of
learning disability that's why
just recently. I think of the
state. Also wanted to adopt or
raise the school level scores.
At some of the local high
schools up by twenty percent.
And again they targeted Boyle
heights by because we were at
the epicenter. Of this
contamination from that thank
you very much for your
comments. Okay I see the real
hard it's real hard to squeeze
like eight years into something
that's why when I understand we
need more meetings that's like.
Not even half of what I got to
play some of it is. Much more
important I. Whether respect
like. Thank thank you we
appreciate that- next we have-
Monsignor John and- that would
be followed by Terry Cano. And
Stephanie Casteel. Yes good
evening thanks for. Here this
evening and- we want to welcome
all of you again and- I just
want to. You at the attic door
last night we had the- H. U. N.
D. was here DTS he was here on
Wednesday night and now you're
committees here. I don't think
Dr Jill it Johnson she's not
here she- she had here tonight
was she was here last night.
Are you familiar with her study
that she did on the baby's
teeth. Now I just leave this
ending. It does show the
urgency of this problem- Dr
Jill. Is a research scientist
at USC that que. The school of
medicine. And she got funded do
this test. To compare the
baby's teeth of our babies
teeth here. As of those two
other area another area. And
when she did this test- if
found out that our babies teeth
in comparison to the amount of
lead. Despite its just bikes in
comparison to the community
that she- said. Our baby's T.
that means. That those babies.
Are will be. I'm not a doctor.
But it is it's a very serious
problem. And SO we live in as
is condition when I. Say that.
It shall eat up to two. Spoons
is a table sponsored table just
is to have a- of doing it a
day- our protocol has been
there for the last. Several
years. They're they're supposed
to wash the feet the did take
their shoes off- don't come
into your dog should wash their
feet before the game. The house
down the food from the floor.
This goes on for years and
years- the final one it just
ask that this equipment aye. No
one's been able to really give
me a good answer. Why is it.
That if this houses been tested
this spend all this money and
testing the house. And they
have agreed the children live
in there. As soon fit all the
qualities. That lead is a
certain level. Why do they have
to go back. Test the parkways
why you said tonight the
details he- told us that it was
going to be UP I think two
thousand and two. Before they
would to finalize our plans
after the do the test. Into
dollars on testing. I'm not a
done I miss. But I seem to me
that logic. Is if I have let in
this. I'm a and with that. Feet
of. It for. From the blog way I
should have lead over there
also just doesn't. Doesn't aye
I've asked this question before
and you just get a B. S.
answers so. I just to submit
that to the people you heard
that figures tonight you're
part of the budget committee so
please- I think this one way we
could save millions of dollars
in and- advance our clean up
faster than it is. Being
program right now thank you
very much thank you. And thank
you again for the use of the
facility- a Terry Cano is next.
Follow by Stephanie because-
and to. I'm not sure if Martha
Jimenez is still here but- may
also have a comment. I can
reach. Okay so- I'm Terry
Connell. I don't even know
where to start first let me
address some of the questions
that I have regarding the
contracts of first and foremost
the sixteen hundred they said
they they could not get access.
To the test. I know resident.
Who wants it who is a part of
that sixteen hundred who wanted
to get their property tested in
this is just a couple of weeks
ago. And we should contact
them. To get her property tax-
tested they said that they were
unable to get those that get
her property tested because
they don't have a current
contract for. Testing those
additional sixteen hundred we
didn't hear that from them. So
unless that's changed like
within the last couple of days.
That's something they should of.
Told you guys so out of those
sixteen hundred that I know of
what they were told what they
told this- property owner was
at the do they do not have a
contract right now to test any
additional homes would you be
able to provide the contact
information for that resident
to the doctor definitely I'll
ask you to- do that at the an
address or to follow at the
last the TSC meeting one of
their their DTS the employees-
did admit that they do not have
a current contract in place to
do. Testing on those sixteen
hundred that there can't they
can't get in contact with and
what brings it. As a community
member. If they can't handle a
contract like this. They don't
have the experience or the know
how to how to handle. A
catastrophe of this of this
magnitude. And I don't send I
don't trust them I don't trust
them to make decisions that are
in the best interest of the
community. And I don't make
trust them to make decisions
that are in the interest of
getting this cleaned up as
expeditiously as as possible I
would ask I would encourage a
auditor to find out why they're
having the problems with the
contractors and it's this isn't
the first time they've had
problems with contractors they
obviously I'm not eight they're
not able to handle that.
Another question regarding the
contracts is. Is American
integrated services. Did they
ever do work both on act on the
excited facility and on the
residential clean up because
that's also something that I'm
interested because I would
think that would be a conflict
of interest. That's something
else that I would hope that you
guys would look into. So of
moving on to the most important
thing to me. As in the- over
six having years that we've
been fighting for excited. The
communities health has been
impacted. There's no question
about that they can say there's
no way to prove this. This
site- these chemicals not just
lead but all the other list of
toxins that they came they put
out. That there's no way to
prove but you can. You can
prove it. Everything that they
put on the list of what led an
arsenic and all of those. Can
can because my family has
suffered. I have most of them.
And there's no hope for me
there is no reversing the
damage that it's done to me and
I'm pretty sure I will not see
the end of the clean up. And
what I have failed to see. Is
since we started this. No
monies. From the state. From
the TSC from anybody. Has gone
to. Help with the health
impacts. We are the worst
casualty of this contamination
yet there is no cleanup of our
human bodies there's no
assistance for us when the US
attorney entered is inter this
agreement and decided. Whether
it was because they have a
government contract to recycle
their batteries or not I don't
know why they entered into this
contract but they took our
ability to see- that that. The
residents are ability to sue
for health damages or financial
assistance to pay for their
chemo their doctors bills there
you know the procedures that
they have to go through. So
we're eating the cost of this
and there is no help for us
what I am asking is if you guys
can find in any budget. To set
up a fund you can give it to
the department of health that
the county health department
let them set up a fund to help.
People pay for their healthcare
costs incurred by the
contamination cost. My copay to
see my oncologist is thirty
five dollars every time I go
see them that's not including
the medications it's not
including the procedures it's
not calling. And I have
excellent insurance. And that
still. Financial financially
hard on me to pay for all of
that. We need something to
address the hit health in the
human impact. The people who
department of health- referring
to for manta for developmental
delays and disabilities in
testing is regional center. Now
through my at my work life I
worked with the regional
different regional centers for
years. East LA regional that
service the area that the- that
covers the impacted area. Has
the most. Clients being service
than any other regional center
anywhere else. They're
referring people there and they
can't even get assessed or or
even or even evaluated because
they don't have the money to.
So money needs to either go to
the organizations that are
being referred to compete were
they're referring people to and
a fun needs to be set up. For
this and the last thing I ask
for funding also. You guys can
find grant or funding for. Dr
Jill Johnston who did the tooth
fairy project. And white
memorial Medical Center doctor
Brian Johnston both of them are
looking into. A study. With the
X. Leyva X. ray fluorescence
machine that will ship and
measure long term exposure.
Only there can a doctor truly
see what you're at risk for and
can understand a little bit
more how it how they can treat
you. We at least deserve that
we at least deserves some
monies going to research care
and anything else that the
county is incurring the cost of.
Humans who were affected are
going to need help for the next
decade the children who were
born into it now argument need
helping care and services
throughout their of their life
not just it doesn't and the
clean up is done so I'm asking
that you guys take that into
consideration thank you thank
you for comments of step. Can
steal. All right all work of
read these questions so what
happens when Sora was re
contaminated. Ray contamination
no edge has been found why and
when will this move out of
preliminary. Ground water was
affected by hex chromium where
are we with this the and PA
listed at us finding. Of the
excite plant. No soil has been
tested since June twenty
nineteen ray residences. Public
dissemination of materials paid
by excited will expire in
twenty twenty the of the anti
any non prosecution agreement
what happens after five year
and PA sunset. The I thank you
for asking those questions this
is an opportunity to provide
public comment but I'm sure
that departments listing and
taking those questions into
consideration at a Martha
menace did you want to add a
comment to what we've already.
And please. Yeah the people
that strategies okay. I don't
want to give that to anyone the
question that I have for the
officers that deal with health
related issues. If we are to do
blood tests are you able to
tell us if five there's lead
that emanated from the- source
of exercise in our
neighborhoods. Yeah there's
been talk about that and
unfortunately for blood testing
no there is there are some ways
in environmental testing that
you can do that sort of work to
try to source the kind of lead
that you finding environment to
the source that it may have
come from. For human testing no
we don't have sophisticated
tests enough that will that can
do that sort of- that's the can
give yes that sort of result
okay. And for supervisor Hilda
cities so what I want to point
out that this is an opportunity
for public comment it's not a
Q. and a- I just wanted to make
a constitutional requests on
behalf of my community can I do
this yes you can make any
request you want. I wanted to
our supervisor Hilda cities if
five she may be able to
increase the number of promote
daughter since paas seven now
that I know that the
representative is here why
because our community from city
terrorists to. Burn in
southeastern cities are
impacted the most impact the
communities for the
environmental issues so I
wanted to know if you may do
that because those people can
be our corporate people they
can going to power the
communities but reaching out.
To them I know that the el
county is looking into getting
more promote taught us to other
districts. By you represent my
district and I have a lot of
faith that you are doing a
great job. One know if made the.
For our community. So a if you
choose to respond now if you
interest later that's fine but
this is not. The is public
comment on on- intended to be a
time when we have dialogue- all
I see. And an observation can
the US army corps of engineers
service sign overseers. Of the
exite our proper this mad. And
the cleanup of the residential
areas scenes they work in pump.
Well the world thank you. Thank
you very much- next we have
Yvonne bike if I could just
respond I know I'm a big
advocate for the moment thought
us and- I know the public
health and mental health have
actually in the last two budget
cycles increase the number of
from a thought as- but keep in
mind that our budget comes from
also the federal government
Sacramento and because we've
been so successful I think with
the small army that we have.
Other supervisors have picked
up on that so I would say that
in most cases unfortunately
they divide by five but we do
know that our our our county
resources- I have always
continue to be supportive of
that and I think maybe working
with the legislature that might
be something that we could try
to carve out funding for the
state because they are affected
their health care navigators-
and they do- culturally
competent. Of information and
they help to encourage people
to get tested for everything
and they certainly could could
be used for to working with the
TSC- DTS I'm sorry do TSC to
get out to the community
because they're the ones that
are most trusted- I don't know
that our capacity maybe there's
something that we could work
with. With the state out on
something like that as we head
but again it a lot of allies on
the budget but it's registered
thank you. Thank you we have if
March what the next and- lastly.
Maximo qureia. Hi good evening
my name is Martinez even
Martinez Watson on the chair of
the environmental justice
committee for the Sierra Club
Angeles chapter. And I just
wanted to mention. There's a
difference between conventional
environmentalism environmental
justice. Conventional my rental
isn't is about see of like
cannibals places. Both types
of- issues environmental
justice is about social justice
it is about getting justice for
people. And the focus is on
people. And that is what's
happening here we have a
situation where the people are
being affected by their
environment. And it is really
unfair for these people to be
having to wait so long to get
justice. Because of the social
justice movement we say justice
delayed is justice denied. And
for the people here who have
children who were five years
old way back when this whole
thing started. And the DTS he
determined that they were going
to start with the houses that
were the most impact it had the
highest levels of lead. Had a
pregnant woman present or five
year old child or any of these
other conditions well we are
way past that. In terms of the
future. And that means that
those people who were back
then. At most risk. For the
adverse effects of lead have
had two indoor it way past the
time that they were determined
they needed to help the most.
So that is not acceptable.
Environmental justice was based
on the concept of environmental
racism. And in this case if
this were a situation happening
in another part of Los Angeles
I guarantee you those people
would have been all over your
cases by now this would not
have been allowed to continue
this long. Something needs to
be done for these people it
needs to be done as quickly as
possible. And it needs to be
done for the people in addition
to their properties. They need
to get some sort of either
compensation or some kind of
assistance with the health
issues that they're going to be
facing because let there is no.
Safe level of lead in your body
none. These people are going to
be dealing with the site these
effects for years for the rest
of their lives. They're already
dealing with the now. If this
had been a communicable disease
such as the one that we're
facing right now from the
corona virus. This one tire
area would have been under
quarantine. And I guarantee you
health department they would
have gone house by house
quarantine everybody. And
making sure that everybody was
covered there would have been
no gaps. There would have been
no properties well you're not
as bad as your neighbor. That's
ridiculous is ridiculous I
heard in this week that there's
a property owner who is
surrounded. Buy properties that
were cleaned up. But because
her whole is in the next tier
contamination she still waiting.
How can you possibly say the
her house is somehow we more
immune than the house around
her. What's going on. No means
what the world is going to
happen to all those people
almost property owners who are
in that next level of
contamination. If we don't have
enough money right now it
resources to handle the people
that were the most contaminated.
Are we just gonna say well
sorry. Yeah you're you're
you're you're properties
contaminated we don't have the
money for it. I'm telling you
this is not home. These people
should be coming up here and
banking you for help. Something
needs to be done has something
in spree done right away thank
you. Thank you for your comment.
Maximo correct. Haven't we
given my yeah. To have a
portable microphone in the back.
Well we'll see. California.
Nine five two four. I hope. You
like the price. To okay when
I'm not changed number not to
meet yeah AB one me what and
Michael the evening I'm like to
meet up to an I live in may
with. Make a mental. Decade
thing would be able is. Get the
lord. Komodo depend on a sure
but he's. Open and then I went.
Jimmy so called Los que
sometimes seven year old has
been so to me eight I can't
play all. My eyes are burning
and I don't know why. Berman me
comment risky. General so
oppose opinion when a was as
you put a juvenile shall also
say that children of the bill
so they're not they're not.
Listening to everybody you all
seem to have a really good
position on wanting to help us
clean the soil I get that-
either one of those he loves
because you're more of a
concept but I have a lot of
neighbor. Already the answer.
It for me to hear okay. Impious
Sam. Ga support crassa. Hello
up of media. When was the most
last time. You you need to go
house house you need to check
each for member and check our
blood levels in C. we're doing.
There's what is this all.
Libyan E. instigator here is up
into rather lookouts Acosta
movie in the back of some low
esos impediment lovers the
numbers game but I'm not able
to possibly so I'm I'm saying
first go to the people. Then
you can go to the soil and then
finally take care of the paint
in those issues and then we can
repair those homes. And does I
go to the vision committee
thinking also him c<c.cyan> c</c>
one able to around. Conocida
you have a little it'll you
okay but the most. Must Cooley
because he won't. We're gonna
so see on. My responsibility
that. But up well there yeah
well they're not that it's.
Super yet though could get in.
Okay we need more organ. This
to be done in a better way it
needed it should have been
rolled out in it in a different
way. I have many neighbors who
come to me who said I'm not
satisfied with the way this is
been done. See if what is a
list when you cook at the
necessary to look at both okay
Mosul the main thing. It is
very necessary that we all work
United together. It will be in
a circle deals with the one of
the system better known as
political the US going like
when you that. Is a necessity.
I request you to that geico was
that my hope. You go to all the
mayor's office as a go to
everybody talk to everyone but
they're really not being
responsive to what needs to be
done and how the work needs to
be. This is just an opera
hometown log on and also low.
But I get much I can't pay it
that they like when you that.
As political support this to me
at least get them to put in the
how about if the next time you
have one of these meetings
during a much bigger place. How
real outrage we're community
members who are going through
this can actually come and stay
with you their stories. But
open it limited to the fullest
assembly the company local like
when you that needs done most.
Democrats voted any settlement
that could rest of total it up
at the numbers went up when is
it going published the project
the that if the after. All
these assembly men and women
who. The so well and but
elected in war they are. You
will do back. To really. To
what we are saying it. Together
and work and coordinating this.
Correctly to the we can clean
our- unity. See if them in the
US okay- up really Jacqui this
is to some of the some please
take a look- but I. But I guess
so. But I'd low not printed on
your conduct testing in though.
But then I don't put as he they
think of him as possible so
what I'm asking the minister
unless you're done you're going
to focus on that the little
also see that. You know
although as far as to say that
maybe these assembly men and
women. Can goal one further.
And do something about Donald
Trump. And what he's doing. To
respond to the issue. That
we're going there right now. I
in up I mean dollar con. You
okay stumble so in the course
of my I mean if assume. He's
this and then the- only gonna.
Because most of in the- lower
by use. His horrible
understanding of the earth warm.
And climate change is really
the basis for a lot of what's
going on he's misunderstanding
is causing. A lot of issues in
my community. It will be Hogan
road that is a second at the
look at I'm a sucker could be
the most and let the other.
Thing is some of what they get
yeah but but as soon but it you
know. Now let's get it but they
can't miss the most what
president of apple also see
that and then you'll see local
that though it. Filled up with.
Us here. We need a president
that looks. Out the and- so. I
include. Children the elderly
everyone. We someone who
believes in what really is
happening with climate change.
Is subtle Sir I'm not going to
disagree with you- but I am
going to ask you to. Stay
focused on the issue that we're
here for today. God bless you
thank you god bless you too Sir
and- thank you. To everyone for
attending tonight thank you to
our- participants- on on our
panels thank you to the
resurrection church- I've I
really appreciate the turn out
tonight on a Friday night you
could be doing other things I
know you're concerned about
this issue. Of care about it
and the- want to see us move
forward as expeditiously as
possible- do any of my fellow
panelists want to. Make a
closing comment. Great then we
will call this meeting
adjourned thank you. You're
welcome which is.